en cette période de noël on le croyait
festif le pétillant traverse pourtant
aujourd'hui une véritable crise depuis
le début de l'année ses ventes se sont
effondrées
frédéric bourillon et vignerons sur
l'appellation de vouvray avec ses 25
hectares il est aujourd'hui très inquiet
le coc vide lui a fait perdre près de
50% de son chiffre d'affaires les
restaurants sont fermés les salles de
spectacles sont fermés les les comment
les traiteurs pour tous qu'événement
ciel mariage
et puis même les les événements des
entreprises tout ça c'est annulé donc le
porno c'était des débouchés importants
et le problème c'est que cette crise
intervient après plusieurs années
difficiles 2016 et 2017 ont été marqués
par le gel les trois années qui ont
suivi ont produit de beaux millésimes
mais avec de très faibles volumes et la
suite ne s'est pas arrangée on a
effectivement aussi le break site qui
depuis deux trois ans les anglais font
très attention sur les nouvelles
nouveaux référencements là on sait pas
les nouvelles taxes qui va y avoir les
incidences au niveau des prix de revente
donc il faudra qu'on baisse nos prix la
taxe trump belle aussi nous a pénalisés
sur le sur le marché américain alors
plus le commune lasser je pense qu'on
peut paraître plus bas ou alors il
faudrait qu'on soit en guerre un
pessimisme dont il est aujourd'hui bien
difficile de sortir du moins dans la
tente d'un véritable déconfinement reste
que tous les vins ne sont pas touchées
de la même façon les vins naturels par
exemple semblent bien résister et puis
il ya la vente sur internet qui se met
peu à peu en place
peut-être ces nouvelles voies
permettront-elles un jour prochain de
faire à nouveau pétiller l'avenir des
vignerons